it's had the perfect segue to swim where
all right but when that rain is over why
not stunt in your swimwear while you
still can the heat is still there one
local swimwear brand has graced the
pages of Sports Illustrated Harper's
Bazaar and style Shape magazine and
owner Kayla Bella is ready to know Grace
short closets too thank you and welcome
to the show thank you I have to admit
she graced my closet too because this
one this is one of my favorite bathing
suits it's so comfortable so beautiful
but let's talk about just the
inspiration behind your brand arrow in
Phoenix yeah it's all about just
empowering people so it's 100
sustainable made from recycled water
bottles actually so it's good for the
environment and really comfortable that
is incredible and also I heard 90s
influence as well let's pop up so her
two very Muses we've got Halle Berry and
Tyra those two were your girls right yes
growing up they were everything
especially as the ones of color so
swimsuits you have to think highly in
Tyra yes Kylie and Tyra's different body
types for everyone right yeah and then
and of course there's a full circle
moment that really kind of makes it all
meant to be what was that full circle
moment with Tyra Banks oh my God it was
so cool so the first year we ended up in
Sports Illustrated she was on the cover
wow so it was just kind of like all
right this is all happening it's all
really taking place it's exciting that
is incredible Sports Illustrated that is
like the Pinnacle of swimwear so let's
talk about what makes your product so
unique besides the sustainability I
think it's color it's texture thank you
yeah so it's the color it's the texture
of the fabric
um everything fits like a Spanx and
we're size inclusive so everything is
extra small to 3XL sizing wise and then
you know to to add to that you're
actually wearing we're seeing the Sports
Illustrated photos right now yeah I love
I love Yeah but also coming back to you
you're actually wearing one of your one
pieces with your jeans so we can go from
swimwear yeah to evening wear bodysuits
crop tops broad tops whatever yeah there
you go there you go so it's it's all
versatile and it's on purpose because
again it goes back to sustainability so
having multi-purpose stuff means that
you don't have to throw things away or
not wear them or have them at the back
of your closet sustainability and
versatility right I love that exactly
me these colors are so special like
chocolate brown bikini yes please what
do you how did you inspire these colors
the colors also are very 90s themed so I
usually think of things that are going
to pop on like every single color skin
tone whether it be a different size or
whatever so that's also coming into play
at the back of my mind always the colors
have to look good across the board you
know what you're doing I love your
bathing suits you guys how can people
get in touch with you or you know look
up your bathing system oh so it's
everything across the board for socials
is at heirloin Phoenix swim we do
pop-ups at the win here locally yeah so
pretty much any night swim you can catch
us over there we have a pop-up this
weekend in La if you're out there at the
Mondrian but you can always find Us
online and on socials for sure well
congratulations on all your success you
are changing the swimwear game JC I'll
send it to you you want this one I do I
want that red one Kayla
I love you